البنك الاهلي وابنك مصر وهما مصر فان
مملوكان للدوله تحركها لاصدار شهادات
استثمار مدتها سنه بفائده 25% الهدف هو
اغراؤه حائز الدولار بتحويل ما لديه
للجنيه للاستفاده من هذا العائد فهل سيقبل
البعض عليها توفير للادرار لغز افياد
يجيب شهادات من اللي هي الجديده دين
العائد بتاعها عالي همم لان الدولار اكيد
اسعاره هتبقى متوازنه في السوق في المرحله
المقبله بعد اصدار هذه الشهاده
بانه بدايه التعويم الثالث لهذا العام
ووصفه اخرون انه دليل على مرونه هذا الصرف
في التماهي مع العرض والطلب
هذا تراجع في قيمه الجنيه امام الدولار
دعا بعض للتشكيك في مدى اقبال المصريين
على هذه الودائع تحرك اسعار الصرف او
انخفاض الجنيه كان مقيمه اكبر بكثير من
الشهادات الطرحه يعني احنا اعلى شهاده
تقريبا طرحت كانت 18% مازال هو اللي اتجه
للشهادات هو برده ما قدرش ان هو يحافظ على
ثروته او
الممتلكات بتاعته مقاومه الدولار
من شانها ان يكذب المصريين للتخلي عن
الدولار مقابل عائد مادي مجزي ولكن في نفس
الوقت هذه الفائده المرتفعه تقول الكثير
عن الغلاء المتوقع في قادم الايام تبين
توقعته الشارع حول معدلات التضخم في
الفتره القادمه
هيحطوا مبالغ كبيره جدا في البنوك فالنقد
اللي معاهم في يديهم هيقل فاعتقد دي هت
كنترول شويه في اسعار السلع يعني الحكومه
المصريه كانت قد اجلت تحريك اسعار
المحروقات والكهرباء كنوع من التخفيف على
المواطنين وبالتالي فهناك ترقب للاجتماع
القادم للجنه المسؤوله عن تحديد سعر
الوقود لان هذا ايضا يشكل عاملا هاما في
تحديد تكلفه السلعه ومن ثم في تحديد
اسعارها تامر ناصر العربيه القاهره